population invitée du 13h en duplex de
l'hôtel de ville martin hirsch
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes président d'emmaüs et vous piquer
un coup de colère ce matin dans le
journal les échos vous avez décidé de ne
plus participer au comité national de
lutte contre l'exclusion pourquoi des
choses sont quand même très paradoxal on
dit à juste titre qu'il faut aider le
retour au travail qu'il faut aider ceux
qui sont exclus du monde du travail et
non pas privilégier l'assistance et là
on a une entreprise d'insertion dans
emmaüs qui emploie 1000 personnes en
difficulté et pour lequel l'état s'était
engagé il ya déjà six mois
apporter un soutien à hauteur de 500000
euros ce qui fait 40 euros par mois et
par salarié et cette promesse n'est pas
tenue
alors quand on dit droits et devoirs
c'est à l'état de donner l'exemple alors
comment justement jugez-vous l'action du
gouvernement dans la lutte contre
l'exclusion
dominique de villepin annonce est il ya
un mois un renforcement des moyens
humains et matériels
est ce vraiment le cas d'un côté vous
voyez ça c'est un exemple de ce que
concrètement sur leur terrain opération
par opération sujet par sujet personnes
en difficulté par personne en difficulté
les gestes ne suivent pas toujours la
parole et on est là nous les
associations pour pouvoir faire
respecter les droits des personnes et
les promesses qui sont tenus alors je
sais qu'il est toujours hasardeux de
résumer la pauvreté à des chiffres ce
sont avant tout des destins humains
mais selon comprennent les critères
français ou européens il y aurait 6 % de
la population en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté chiffres français 12% si on
prend les chiffres européens ou situe la
vérité la vérité elle est dans une
situation qui s'aggrave
c'est à dire que les frontières de la
pauvreté sont de plus en plus brouillé
avec des gens qui même quand il tire un
fil ne peuvent pas s'en sortir quand on
tire un fil vers l'emploi on peut rester
travailleurs pauvres
moi je dis aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de bouclier fiscal pour les plus riches
il faut mettre un bouclier social pour
les plus pauvres que le retour à
l'emploi sa garantie ce qu'on garde 60%
des revenus qu'on avait avant et qu'on
puisse franchir le seuil de la pauvreté
je trouve qu'un enfant qui a une mère
qui travaille et qui pourtant va vivre
sous le seuil de pauvreté
c'est strictement inacceptable dans
notre pays merci à vous martin sheen
d'être intervenu en direct
de l'hôtel de ville dans le 13 heures